oh cancer it's growing day by day a
prediction based report shows that in
last decade there is a 45 percent
increase in cancer cases now in this
video we would talk about the causes of
cancer now definitely you know that
there are carcinogens and their
cancer-causing agents such as cigarette
smoke etc but apart from that there is
another important cause of cancer which
is genetic
now this genetic cause of cancer is due
to gene mutations now which genes are
mutated in this context I'll introduce
the concept of proto-oncogene and on
koujun now any cell need to grow and in
order to grow they need to divide and
increase their number and also their
size so there are set of genes known as
proton Co genes which aid in this
process
so simply proto oncogenes are those
genes which are absolutely necessary for
normal cell growth proliferation and
division there are other type of genes
known as tumor suppressor genes tumor
suppressor genes as the name suggests
the suppress the tumor growth or they
suppress the uncontrolled proliferation
or growth of the cells now due to some
reason if there is a mutation in either
of these uncle chain or the tumor
suppressor gene then the consequence
could be detrimental a gain of function
mutation in the proton Cugine would
convert it into own cuisine whereas a
loss of function mutation in the tumor
suppressor gene can reduce its ability
to suppress the tumor or uncontrolled
growth as a result what would happen is
uncontrolled growth when cell division
is uncontrolled it might ultimately lead
to tumor formation and which might turn
into cancer now let's just look at
cellular at a cellular level how these
proto-oncogenes could be a component of
grow
signaling pathway now as I depicted
earlier that proto-oncogenes are
absolutely necessary for growth
division and survival
so definitely anything any component of
the growth signaling pathway which
indigenously give rise to group of cells
or tissue if it goes wrong then it might
create a cancer like situation so these
mutations or these changes could occur
at the ligand level such that the growth
factor level the growth factor binding
receptor level the intracellular signal
transduction molecular level or even at
the very downstream the transcription
factor level so I will disguise discuss
and describe all of the examples one by
one so stay tuned the first step is the
receptor where the ligand binds you can
imagine if then any mutation caused over
production of any growth factor or a
mitogenic signal that might lead to
cancers like situations other than that
receptors which are receptors for growth
factors such that human epidermal growth
factor receptor 2 or hard to acquire a
mutation in its valiant chain in its
valiant residual and convert it into
glutamine residue as a result the
receptor is locked in an active
conformation it is auto phosphorylated
without the binding of any ligand and as
a result the downstream signal is always
active this her2/neu protein is known as
an uncle protein and one of the
prevalent cause of breast cancer another
example is EGF receptor which is turned
into a truncated erbB oncoprotein which
is also constitutively active and
doesn't need any binding of ligand to
signal downstream it always signal
downstream in a constitutive fashion now
one of the most important pathways for
normal growth and proliferation is map
kinase pathway in a map kinase pathway
the mitogen which is a growth factor
binds to its receptor
many of the cases the receptor is
receptor tyrosine kinase and in this
pathway one gtps is very important which
is rath unlike just like it's a cousins
in g-protein couple signaling pathway
rath also need GTP for its function but
this GTP the GTP bound grass could also
be converted into an inactive state by a
gap protein which is GTP as activator
protein and as a result just like the
switch signaling could be switched on
the signaling could be also switched off
but there are many many mutations in the
wrasse which makes wrasse and uncle
protein because in a mutated grass it is
always bound to gdp even if the gap
protein is able to bind to the wrasse
GTP it cannot hydrolyze the GTP and as a
consequence grass is always active
considerably active and the downstream
signaling pathway is always on
regardless how much signal is present in
the environment or how much growth
factor is present in the environment as
a consequence there is a huge amount of
output in the map kinase signaling
pathway since map kinase signaling
pathway is one of the key prevalent
growth signaling pathway which one of
the important target of map kinase
signaling pathway is cyclin d and we all
know that cyclin d Sirica for complex
allow the transition from g1 to s phase
so any aberrant mutation in this map
kinase pathway components or cyclin d
etc can lead to uncontrolled
proliferation and growth which might
lead to cancer so these genes which are
a normal component of the growth
signaling pathway or which regulate cell
cycle progression regulates survival
these jeans are proton Cugine but any
loss of function or any gain of function
mutation in them would allow them to be
converted into an oncogene or an active
oncogene which might give rise to
uncontrolled proliferation and cancer
now mutation in several transcription
factor can also lead to cancer and a
live example is false
another thing is many cases mutations
might stabilize the mRNA namely the
false mRNA is normally degraded at a
stable rate at a steady state rate but
the overproduction of the foss would
happen or the stabilization of this
force could happen due to some mutation
in its mRNA as a result the output of
the might the map k pathway would be
huge so there is a huge amount of map k
pathway output as a result there could
be uncontrolled growth and risk of
cancer now chromosome translocation at a
big picture can give rise to cancer you
might wonder how so let's say I give you
a specific example so here is a
chromosome where a gene known as C make
marked in red is situated now the C make
due to translocation change its position
C make which was earlier located in this
small yellow chromosome now get
incorporated near vicinity of a gene IgH
which ultimately caused Burkitt's
lymphoma now this kind of situation
happens because the I gh is highly
highly expressive gene in these cells
and when C make comes under its
influence of this enhancer it causes a
huge production of C me which might
ultimately give rise to cancer many of
the cancers are associated with this
kind of chromosomal inversions in
chromosomal translocations such at
Burkitt lymphoma diffusive large b-cell
lymphoma follicular lymphoma and mantle
cell lymphoma all these things happens
all or all of these cases are normal
gene which is regulating growth is
coming back coming into the influence of
a gene which is high
highly expressed and as a result those
genes which are giving rise to normal
growth is excessively produced and as a
consequence it is giving rise to
uncontrolled growth and thereby cancer
now I'll take you through some other
aspects of it normally a cell has
programmed its own death pathway using
several specific enzymes known as
caspase which are in inactive form
normally but when a signal related to a
death cue appears these gas phases are
cleaved one such kind of bit cue could
be damaged in the DNA so all these
things would lead to apoptosis by
activation of the caspase-3 now there
are specific genes which are pro
apoptotic helps in apoptosis and thereby
regulate the homeostasis of cellular
proliferation by maintaining a proper
turnover of a cell now what happens in
case of many cancers these pro-apoptotic
genes are suppressed whereas the
anti-apoptotic genes such as PCL 2 and
bcl-xl etc are over produced or up
regulated as a result cell never dies
literally the cell would become immortal
and show uncontrolled growth and other
tumor cell like phenotypes now apart
from all of these we know that every day
we know that cell could ultimately lead
to cancer when it is more stabilized and
the pro-apoptotic genes are down
regulated now our cells has DNA inside
the nucleus and DNA is undergoing damage
every time let's say by some to be
radiation or anything but there are
mechanisms which can first of all detect
the damage and second of all there are
maintenance mechanism which can repair
these DNA damage must imagine a
situation where there is a mutation
itself in the DNA repair machinery or
the
damage detection system which might not
detect this kind of mistakes and
overlook this kind of mistakes as a
result there would be overall more
mutations and as a result there is a
high probability that these
proto-oncogenes would be activated in
form of a uncle gene and that might lead
to uncontrolled growth and cancer so
that was my old video on proto-oncogene
I hope this video was informative if you
like my video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
thank you